in a new poll 68  of fox news viewers are blaming antifa  for the january 6 riots there is no  actual evidence that antifa had  anything to do with the riots and think  of it for a second the defendants from  the rioting  their entire online history has been  looked at they've looked at everything  if these people were antifa pretending  to be trump supporters they've been  doing it for years  before there was even the idea of the  january 6 riot sometimes you have to  apply  a sort of casual version of occam's  razor which of these explanations  requires the fewest assumptions the  apparent trump supporters on january 6  were really antifa who pretended to be  trump supporters on social for four  years even though there was no pla  or  the trump supporters were just trump  supporters